>> HOW IS EVERYTHING?
>> CAN'T WAIT UNTIL LONGER.
YOU ANNOUNCE THE WINNER OF THE
FIRST-TIME AWARD.
>> WINNER OF THE FIRST KAREEM
ABDUL-JABBAR SOCIAL JUSTICE
AWARD IS CARMELO ANTHONY.
I TALKED TO CARMELO EARLIER.
HE WAS SO HAPPY.
>> I WAS --
>> SHOULD I GIVE HIM A CHANCE TO
RESPOND?
>> SURE.
>> NO, I WAS HAPPY.
WE SPOKE EARLIER.
YOU KNOW, YOU ALREADY KNOW HOW I
FEEL ABOUT THIS AWARD.
I RECEIVED A LOT OF AWARDS
THROUGHOUT MY LIFE AND CAREER
BUT THIS AWARD RIGHT HERE MEANS
A LOT MORE THAN ANY OTHER AWARD
I'VE EVER RECEIVED.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE OF THE
TIMES WE ARE IN.
WHAT WE'RE DEALING WITH IN THE
COUNTRY AND AROUND THE WORLD,
ALSO IN OUR COMMUNITY.
SO FOR ME TO RECEIVE THE AWARD,
ALL THE GREAT FINALISTS INVOLVED
IN THIS, ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
COULD HAVE BEEN ON THIS LIST,
IT'S THE FIRST ONE, IT'S YOUR
FIRST AWARD, TO HONOR ME IN
THAT, I'M HUMBLED BY RECEIVING
THAT.
>> MELO --
>> THANK YOU.
>> I JUST WANT TO SAY, SO MANY
THINGS WERE DONE BY THE FIVE
FINALISTS, I COULDN'T MAKE A
RIGHTEOUS CHOICE, WANTED TO GIVE
ALL YOU GUYS A GRANT FOR WHAT
YOU'RE DOING.
I'M GLAD I HAD HELP SORTING IT
OUT.
AND I'M JUST REALLY PROUD OF YOU
AND PROUD OF THE NBA.
I WANT TO SAY THAT.
NBA STARTED THIS A LONG TIME
AGO, AND CARMELO STARTED THIS A
LONG TIME AGO.
15 YEARS AGO WITH THE CARMELO
ANTHONY FOUNDATION, AND BEEN
DOING GREAT WORK EVER SINCE.
LIKE I SAID, I'M PLEASED AND
PROUD TO HAVE YOU AS FIRST
RECIPIENT, CARMELO.
GOD BLESS.
>> IT'S MY HONOR, DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THAT FOR SURE.
>> MELO, DURING THE PANDEMIC, WE
HAD THIS SERIES OF
CONVERSATIONS, NBA TOGETHER, WE
DID ZOOMS AND WE SPOKE ABOUT 45
MINUTES ON ONE OF THOSE.
YOU'RE GROWING UP IN NEW YORK
AND BALTIMORE AND WHAT YOU
EXPERIENCE THERE, HOW DID THAT
PREPARE YOU FOR LATER LIFE AND
FOR BEING SOMEBODY WHO IS NOT
AFRAID TO GO TO THE FOREFRONT IN
SOCIAL MATTERS?
>> WELL, IT PREPARED ME WITHOUT
ME EVEN KNOWING.
BEING A PRODUCT OF YOUR
ENVIRONMENT, YOU'RE JUST GOING
THROUGH IT, DEALING WITH ISSUES
AS IT COMES, PEOPLE AS IT COMES,
GOOD PEOPLE, BAD PEOPLE,
WHATEVER, YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THAT.
AND YOU TAKE THAT AT FACE VALUE.
FOR ME, I ALWAYS WANTED SOMEBODY
TO COME BACK TO MY HOOD AND SAY
NO, YOU CAN DO THIS.
OR NEXT KID, YOU CAN GIVE US
HOPE.
NOBODY NEVER GAVE ME HOPE, MY
COMMUNITY HOPE.
FOR ME TO BE IN SITUATION NOW
15-PLUS YEARS I'M ABLE TO GIVE
BACK NOT JUST TO BALTIMORE AND
NEW YORK BUT PORTLAND, PUERTO
RICO, I SPENT TEN-PLUS YEARS ON
THE ISLAND BUILDING COURTS AND
SOCCER TEAMS AND BUSINESSES DOWN
THERE TO GIVE BACK TO MY PEOPLE,
TO THE ISLAND.
THIS IS